have increased strength and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
speaking of artists how dare you how
dare you you always dare so greatly in
your roles but i'm wondering if this was
a dare for you in the sense of and when
you said this in a previous interview 30
years and this is your first lead
what kind of a risk or dare was that for
you as an actor
i mean i i appreciate that and you know
i i i have fought hard to get these
opportunities where i'm able to dive in
and take
big swings and i really love that and
when i was asked to do morbius there was
a few things that excited me number one
this character's never been on screen
before and i to have the first
to introduce this character audiences
for the very first time is a pretty big
honor so there's that and the fact that
it was this really physical
transformation kind of seemed suited to
me
uh for me you know there there are
really three characters in one here um
and i really uh i love that there was a
big
problem to solve a big challenge here
and
uh yeah i had a lot of fun with it
surprised that you said three characters
i would have thought too and i wanted to
ask you first of all you do you have
physically transformed for so many roles
but i was curious about the two comic
book films joker versus morbius when you
are in that zone because i know you get
super immersed can you sort of describe
sort of the difference between being
immersed as joker and immersed as
morbius full morbius
you know for me
every part that i play is really
different
um
someone was saying the other day they
would love to see all these characters
in one room have a conversation uh
and
you know i i suppose you know when i'm
looking at characters anyway you know
exploring the differences rather than
the similarities is a fun place to start
but uh whether it's
paolo gucci
uh or we crashed
or morbius or requiem or whatever else
um uh little things
it's it's really fun to craft these
characters and for me they're they're
they're it's it they're they're like
real people
um you know they're they're like
they're they're alive in some way and
you know and
in my heart
and in my head uh
and i get quite cl close to the the
characters
um
uh but it's been it's a great
it's a great privilege to be able to
take on
such a diverse
group of characters and a really
challenging group of characters
and i love that i fought really hard for
that opportunity and i always make sure
that i push myself
and hopefully deliver you know something
that's exciting for audiences
speaking of pushing yourself i know some
of the cast
has talked about you know people talk
about how you transform for a role but
in this you transform within a scene
from dr michael morbius to full-on
morbius i'm thinking about the cage
scene in particular where your body is
contorting your face is contorting and
they shoot that so close up and that
transformation is really visceral in
your face i'm wondering for you as an
actor
how
how that was to sort of transform within
a scene
it was exciting um you know this is one
of the reasons that i i pushed hard to
use uh cg to use uh
rather than prosthetics because i
thought that would free us up to to do
things like that to change on a moment's
notice and i think that's something
special about the characters the way we
go in and out
uh
and
surprise and and delight audiences that
that's a lot of fun
how would you compare the physicality
like the fighting scenes i'm thinking
like back to like fight club
that sort of raw i think you said you
got hit a couple of times versus the
fight scene in this film
well we had a great team of of like
fight coordinators and you know stunt
men and women and it just was
the absolute best of the best so
you know i was in their hands and they
they really uh
they make me and morbius look good
uh and uh you know i adore them okay
let's get sinister for a second i know
you've talked about how there's a much
bigger world coming
um everybody's sort of waiting for that
announcement i think it's kind of the
inevitable there's going to be a
sinister six but who would you sort of
first of all
which of the spider-man iterations would
you be most excited to sort of go to toe
to toe with and then also
which of the sort of more sinister
characters would you be more most
excited to sort of team up with
well you know i love all the
spider-man's they're such terrific
actors um tom holland though is is is a
new chapter and morbius is a new chapter
so that probably makes the most sense
and um
and as far as
sinister six
you know
who knows i mean it would be great to
get in the ring with venom
uh but also um
[Music]
you know you have blade and
a lot of other characters out there so
uh who knows we'll see what happens i
know kevin and amy have both said that
they're waiting for a team up i mean in
the comics you and blade were
you know he was chasing you quite a bit
so yeah and the opportunity to shoot
with mahershala i'm sure would be
amazing yeah that would be absolutely
incredible such such great actors it
would be a privilege to work with any of
them
um so i want to talk about
i know you do a lot of preparation and
i'd
if this is a weird question but did you
study i know you probably delved into
maybe vampire movies did you study in
any of the previous mcu any of the
previous spider-mans but particularly
did you study bats and the
characteristics because your movements
very much had that quality
i mean you know that that's what's
look when you take on a roll you you
it's your job to look at turn over every
rock right you never know where you're
gonna find something that inspires you
uh and in this case there was this huge
amount of material in these comic books
and this beautiful artwork over the
years and a lot of different writers had
interpretations of this character so i
just kind of dove in and
um explored and it was buried in
material and you know and then it was my
job to interpret this character in a
different way
uh
uh and you know it was quite an honor to
do that for the very first time all our
lives we've lived with death why
shouldn't they know what it feels like
for a change
just accept who you are
the bad guy
so first of all love your work big fan
super excited to talk to you about this
film i know for last night in soho you
talked a lot about how edgar wright gave
you like a whole library of movies to
watch to sort of delve into the role i'm
wondering if that extended to this are
you now a marvel
aficionado sony have you seen all the
spider-mans
the comic book lore like how did you
sort of explore and immerse yourself in
this world yeah well of course you know
i sort of i i made myself familiar with
the world i needed to make myself
familiar with in the in the morbius or
more biotic that isn't even a word to
sense i like it what what i am an
aficionado of is vampires and vampire
movies i love that i'm not meant to say
that because we're not going to talk
about vampires but that's the truth i
love them i love love vampire films and
so all of my life really i've sort of
sought them out
and um edgar was really amazing for that
actually he he gave me a great list of
vampire movies um because he's got a
list of you know great ev everything
movies so yeah i i watch a lot of that
stuff
i can tell because it's kind of extended
into your look today so what's up what's
one that you would sort of say would be
like a good pairing to watch with this
film oh with this movie well look only
because it's mentioned and it's really
boring and really obvious but i just
think you you sort of have to watch lost
boys with this because the league
characters called michael and i knit
straight out of it
saying a word like michael
and and i just as a little sort of nod
to one of my favorite ever vampire films
i love the lost voice and until you said
that i didn't remember that that is a
call back to that film but it was
reminding me of something well there you
go you see it's in the ether
something else was reminding me of
something your dance scene in this movie
i watched it and i was like hold on this
is reminding me of something first of
all i want to know if that was
choreographed down to a science or
whether they just let you freewheel it
because i'm calling it the i'm feeling
myself dance like i'm feeling really
good about myself i got a little bit of
spider-man 3 vibes maybe a little bit of
joker and i know you love joaquin
phoenix i know you've said before
so tell me about crafting the dance well
it was just a one-off thing and actually
we shot it sort of yeah we shot it at
the end and it wasn't no it wasn't
choreographed they just played some
music on the day
and um
you know they were like
do something in the mirror and i was
like okay and that's that's why i love
working with daniel because he's got the
confidence and freedom to let something
like that just evolve and it doesn't
have to be sort of overly precise and so
he lets you play and we messed around
and there it is you know what are you
dancing to what was the song i think
it's sort of a swedish song actually
because he's from sweden
and i'd never heard it and i had an idea
i wanted to play
i don't know like the stone roses or
something really english he was like no
no this is it this is this is going in
the movie so you're doing it to this i
was like okay cool but it was cool
because it sort of it had a sort of
weird rhythm to it
yeah no it was it was a vibe and by the
way much better dance skills than
spider-man 3 no offense really no
offense to toby but yeah you know much
better dance skills but it was kind of
reminding me of that like i'm really
coming into myself moment um from dance
scenes to fight scenes
i i mean this was a really physical role
i'm sure
i'm wondering and what was interesting
about it was the morphing that took
place but i haven't i don't think i've
seen a film like this where the morphing
happens so like in your face between
your face and the fight scenes do you
have to sort of like overact as an actor
because some of them i'm sure is i don't
know how much was makeup i'm sure
but how do you sort of tweak your
performance knowing that they're going
to add cg in to it sadly i you know it's
sort of my default to overact so that's
sort of coming up
i do that bit no do you know what it is
right it's really it's sort of simpler
than it looks on the day they just put
all those dots on your face so you do
your performance and then you might do a
bit of a sort of a facial move or
whatever and then once the movie's made
you go into what looks like a padded
cell they put you in a helmet with a
sort of arm on and a camera pointing at
you and all these other cameras around
you and then you do what is i suppose
monster acting but these cameras and the
way they film it is so intricate and
clever it allows
it allows that symbiotic technical thing
to happen it's very clever really it's
nothing to do with me it's all those
clever cgi guys well done you
however you just lit up when you talked
about it in that monster face you just
said i i want two more hours of that
monster face
you don't you don't i think you would
have punched it in the head by the end
of it
i know uh jared you know people have
talked about what an immersive actor he
is he really gets into character want to
know sort of for you how the two of you
um i don't know what your process is
and how the sort of two of you work
together and crafting that dynamic well
it was very interesting actually because
i
i i
he's a sort of method actor or what you
would demon method i suppose so you
don't meet him before the first day on
set
that's it that's the first time i ever
met jared was day one of the shoe and it
was a scene
it was the scene in when there's all the
bats and he finds the cure and we both
got the stick and i get really cross
with him and say why would you give this
to me as well
so i was really nervous obviously
because it's your first day and you're
meeting jared leto and you're playing
this part so but that it does something
quite interesting it's sort of
that it's it's an interesting process
i'd be keen to do it again you know have
to say
there's room in that world uh speaking
of fights scene was more intense the
fight scenes in this film or house of
the dragon because i know your character
is quite intense and quite a warrior and
what can you sort of tease about how how
your character in that series is going
to differentiate itself from the books
well you know i like with everything i
think you try and sort of subvert things
a little bit don't you and i hope with
damon targaryen i've done a bit of that
the truth is i don't know because i've
not seen any of it but the fight scenes
in that were intense because you're in
armor and the swords are huge and it's
just again it's just there's no there's
so much in it it's called you're
constantly fighting all the time for
like nine months
because you know he's a dragon rider so
that's his sort of stick but um i don't
know what it's going to be like i have
no idea i've not seen i've not seen
anything
exciting so back to this film um did you
talk to anybody else like any of the
other characters that played spider-man
anybody in the mcu sort of before during
or after about this experience yeah i
spoke to karen gillan who plays nebula
because she's one of my best friends
and i was like you know what's it like
what's the deal what's it like being in
a mall but she was like go do it do one
um but that was it really she's she's
the only person i know
who i mean yeah yeah that i spoke to in
depth about it but she was really sort
of encouraging she was fabulous there
are limits there has to be there's
something inside of
he wants to hunt
and consume blood
cool
so first of all congratulations on the
film i know i didn't speak to tyrese
about it but i heard him talking about
daniel your style as a director he said
you're very you know quick like it's a
fast-paced set he said you will not
hesitate to tell somebody if they're not
giving you what you want you're very
blunt i want to ask you about that and
then also you as an actress did you how
did you experience um that on your part
on my part all right so you start oh so
i start no but i mean i i can talk about
i mean i just think that therese is a
lovely human being and and it became
like a very good friend and
you know i hope i was never
you know blunt or harsh with him but but
i think that
that's my job no is is to really help
the actors um
you know find that their truth you know
and the
and with the with all of them al
madrigal
uh adria therese
jared harris it was a beautiful
experience to be able to be so honest
and present with them you know
and and yeah yeah no but he said it in a
complimentary way he appreciated it
yes i love him you know he's
like a good good close friend you know
yeah no he said you brought out the best
in him so audrey what about you yeah you
know i i think
sort of like tyree said but i think you
know you would show up on set and and i
think
the bar was set so high and and and
daniel made sure that
one to protect us he only wanted us to
succeed and knew our limits and and
really wanted to take us through the
true truth the most truthful version
of each scene
um
yeah and i don't think he was pampering
egos and nor would i ever want him to
for that i go somewhere else
you know i i want i want him i want him
to tell me yes i'm doing good or no so i
can go home and you know
go to sleep and i don't have to be
doubting in my mind did i do a good job
did i do a bad job i know i would leave
set knowing that if he said we're moving
on i 100 knew
we were moving on i would appreciate
that too i love feedback i'm like
communicate communicate communicate
please
for you daniel how did you shoot because
it's the first time i think i've ever
seen in a comic book film the face
morphing so close up i want to know how
you shot that and how did you direct
your actors because i asked matt i said
did you have to overact a little bit
when you knew the face was going to
morph and he says well i think i always
over act a little bit but how did you
how did you shoot those scenes
i mean in many ways you know
technology has gotten so far so so
uh i would ask you know all of them to
when they were in front in you know in
store for for a transformation that they
would try to embody the soul of the of
the character and i mean you should see
you know jared leto becoming morbius
without the special effects it's still
mike it's still morbius it's still
visceral it's still dangerous
it's still frightful you know so it all
stems from him it is his performance
we are
merely tool crafters that you know yeah
but you know we are we just fix it i
think andrea youth talked about watching
jared do the cage scene and said that
maybe like he was terrifying like even
the crew i heard was like whoa whoa
um what was like what was it like to
sort of
be because i knew he's a very immersive
actor was that a different experience
for you and how did you experience doing
scenes with him yeah i mean it's
certainly a different style of working i
think it's a lot easier because he gave
me a good reference to sort of react
from as opposed to you know someone else
that might be like no they'll be in
special effects i'll go there and then i
everything sort of relies on the
reaction of the person that makes it
feel and look real um and jared didn't
do that jared was there and he went
there 100 which made
my job just so much easier because
you know it was terrifying to
watch him do that i felt like all his
veins were going to pop out of his head
and his neck um
and the way he contorted his body
you know i like daniel said i want to
see the version without the special
effects because i think it will be
equally as as good after scenes there
you go daniel um i wanted to ask you
follow up and ask you a question about
you are sort of like the most
level-headed of the trio between loxius
and morbius you're sort of like the
person that keeps her head
all three characters very very smart but
what was important for you
in creating your character and creating
that sort of dynamic and the trio um
amongst each of you
well i mean
i think i'm a woman and i have that by
nature i think when in doubt call a
woman and she'll sort of
she'll sort of
put all the stuff together and re-puzzle
everything
um
i think it was i think it was quite
easy those those dynamics to sort of
create i think we we had established a
good relationship with me and dr morbius
and
and sort of that she's almost like an
anchor to dr morbius and a protector and
loves him
blindly and sort of risks everything for
him and for his well-being so anybody
that sort of
comes near him or has a
male intention
sort of
triggers martine a little bit and i
think martin knew that you know that
milo was i think martine feels milo as a
trigger i think way before
a lot of a lot of things go down and
sensibilities always um daniel what i
really appreciated i watch a lot of
movies and a lot of superhero movies and
one thing i really appreciate about the
way you shot the action was sometimes
when i watched
a superhero and i see the wide shot and
they're zipping along and then you see
them close-up punch and you can tell
it's not the same power everything in
this was super high speed and you used a
lot of color there was like a purple
color with more bs can you sort of talk
about crafting those action scenes and
why was it important for you to set a
different tone than maybe we've seen
before
i wanted it to be a more kind of
immersive
experience i wanted us to become like
one of those people you know that were
running along with them you know that
where we were inside of the action we
were not watching it from afar so
so i was hoping to to give you give us
an an immersive experience and i think
in an immersive experience is a
psychedelic
you know not that i've had like a big
experience of psychedelia but
but um
you know i was aspiring to give a little
bit of that to the audience audra for
you uh future i know
everybody's waiting for a sinister six
movie maybe a possible team up with
spidey which character would you
personally as an actress like to team up
with in the future
in a future film team up with or fight
against either which which as an actress
which um actor or character
look i really i really love and admire
tom holland um and what he's done i
think he got that role so young and ass
killed it he's done such an amazing job
he's so funny
um i think he's a great actor uh i think
he's a really great spider-man so i mean
i would i would want to see something
there right
or no
of course i mean
it's you it's you it's your question
well what would you like to do i mean
you can answer the question too for
yourself yeah i think jared and i they
asked us this in mexico and the both of
us was like there was like tom holland i
think
but i mean i would like to see you know
if i could cross any kind of universe
you know against each other i think it
would be awesome to see
uh morbius fight wolverine
i think that would be great oh yeah
who would win
excellent and they both had the nails
then they both had the nails no it's
very it's a very very very interesting
fight who the hell are you mad i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service
you